JAY JUDKOWITZ: This is a
presentation on persistent
disk, or as we affectionately
call it, PD.
My name is Jay Judkowitz.
I'm a product manager for PD.
This is Andrew Kadatch,
our tech lead.
And it's a 30 minute
presentation where we'll go
through what persistent disk is,
what we use it for, how it
works, what are some of the main
beneficial properties to
you as developers.
And then, we're going to spend
most of our time, actually
Andrew, talking about
the best practices--
how you get the most out of it,
how you protect it, how
you get some advanced
use out of it.
And then, we'll try to save 10
minutes at the end for Q&A.
So let's jump right into it.
So the first thing we like to
say we talk about persistent
disk is talk about the context
of the rest of cloud storage.
A lot of our cloud storage
offerings are actually managed
data, whether it's a blob, or
a NoSQL database with data
store, or Cloud SQL, which
is kind of a MySQL
implementation, or Big Query.
But every now and then, you
don't want managed data.
Every now and then, you want to
manage the data yourself.
And you need raw
block devices.
So Google has two block devices
for this purpose.
One is the scratch devices,
which we used to call
ephemeral disk.
Those live and die with VMs.
A VM is created.
You get the scratch disk.
And then, when you
kill the VM, the
scratch disk goes away.
Persistent disk is,
well, persistent.
You create it independently of
a virtual machine, mount it
and unmount it from the virtual
machine as you need,
and can mount it to a new
VM if the first VM dies.
Basically, persistent disk is a
cloud-wide SAN for your use.
Three primary use cases
for persistent disk.
First is as a boot device.
So you can boot off of
persistent disk if you have a
stateful application, one that
you need its configuration to
survive after you shut it down
and turn it on many times.
The more common use case right
now is as a data drive.
So regardless of whether you're
booting off of scratch
or persistent disk, if you're
running a data store like HDFS
file system for Hadoop, if
you're running an NFS server,
a MySQL database, a NoSQL
database like Mongo or
Cassandra, having a persistent
disk as a data drive is the
way to keep that data
living across
instantiations of that database.
And obviously, to keep it highly
available so you never
lose that data.
The last use case is actually
really unique to Google.
And let me start with
the use case here.
Imagine you're some scientific
computing application
developer, or you're doing
some sort of render farm.
And you have data that you
create once, but then need it
available to many workers.
Many workers are going to
compute on this genomic data,
or on this image.
So persistent disk gives you
an option as opposed to
copying it everywhere.
Instead of copying it to every
worker, you can just mount the
persistent disk to very large
numbers of virtual machines.
And they'll have instant
access to it.
So this can scale to at
least hundreds of VMs.
So before I get into how
persistent disk works, we'll
talk about one of our partners
who's had a lot of success
with persistent disk and
their customers.
People are probably pretty
aware of MapR.
They're a Hadoop distributor.
And they basically used the
first two use cases of
persistent desk.
They encourage their customers
to use it as a boot drive
always because they want the
Hadoop cluster configuration
to survive death and restart
of instances.
And then, they also will
suggest some of their
customers use it as
the data disks.
The MapR FS can, if you lose a
scratch disk, let's say, can
replicate the data.
But if you lose the entire
cluster and bring it back up,
you would have to re-import
the data.
So if you're going to shut down
and restart entire Hadoop
clusters, it's better
to use persistent
disk on the back end.
Now, the concern that they had
going into it was performance.
In other clouds, people say, oh,
you have to use ephemeral
disk for something
like Hadoop.
They were very pleasantly
surprised.
They found that persistent disk
performed about as fast
as ephemeral disk
in other clouds.
And they were able to
consistently get 120 megabytes
per second through the
persistent disk using their
application how they tuned it.
So let's talk a little bit
about how persistent disk
works so we can get to why some
of those benefits exist.
So the first thing to note is
that a persistent disk is not
actually a real disk.
It's a virtual volume that is
made up of blocks from many,
many underlying physical
devices.
And so one block is cut up,
and striped, and smeared
across many, many-- it could
be hundreds or thousands of
physical devices.
Now, each of those blocks
is encrypted,
which is critical because--
I'm sure you've talked about
security in a lot
of the other sessions.
You want to make sure there's
absolutely no circumstances
where somebody else can
get to your data.
On top of the security, we
also do check summing.
When you retrieve data that
you've stored, you want to
make sure that it's exactly
the data that you had.
So we take care of this all
underneath the covers.
We will not return bad
data to you ever.
Now, let's talk about what
we do with that data for
performance.
So the first thing is, we're
going to optimize for random
writes by basically writing
anywhere in the cloud that we
feel is a good fit for that
block at that time.
So this is going to help you.
Let's use a database use case.
If you're doing a lot of
transactions that are randomly
writing all across your
database, you don't know who
the user's going to come in,
what transaction they're going
to do, or where in the database
you need to write to.
You want to know that every
write is going to go to a good
part of the cloud that isn't
affected by a noisy neighbor
and gets you consistent rate
performance, even with
randomness.
And then, moving over to reads,
what you'll notice
about these copies, what's
interesting is it's not an
active-passive copy.
Each one of those copies can
actively take reads.
So we will get a read from the
first guy that responds.
We'll put out the
read everywhere.
Whoever comes back first wins.
Again, this is going to add to
consistency of performance.
So now, if you're trying to
figure out, oh, how much data
and how much I/O do I put to a
particular data volume before
I create a new database shard,
that doesn't become an
exercise in randomness.
That actually--
you can apply a very specific
formula to that
based on your workload.
Now, moving away from data
volumes back to boot volume
use case, what we do is, again,
we can boot from PD.
The PD is striped, spread out
across lots of volumes.
But what happens when we create
another copy of the VM
that has high commonality
with the previous one?
Well, very, very soon-- it's
not released this moment.
But very soon, we'll basically
be able to create a new copy
with basically virtually
referencing the previously
copied blocks so that you get an
extremely fast deploy time.
And the idea--
like so when you guys
saw [? Urzhi's ?]
talk this morning and Greg's
demo, the idea that you could
do like 1,000 VMs in five
minutes, right?
We can do that, and we're
looking to get even faster.
And of course, even though
they're reading off of shared
blocks, we're not going
to corrupt it.
If you add a block to one or
change a block on another,
that's going to be a new write
elsewhere in the persistent
disk cloud and not going to
corrupt the shared blocks.
This slide gets to another
extremely unique feature of
Google Cloud, but it's not
persistent disks only.
It's in teaming up with Google
Cloud Storage, or
GCS, or blob storage.
So the common thing that
everybody knows about is if I
wanted to be able to copy data
to another site, whether it's
for VM migration, backup,
disaster recovery, I can
snapshot my block device
into a blob store.
A lot of other clouds have
the ability to do
differential snapshots.
So I only have to copy
the changes.
This is something we'll
be coming out with
very soon as well.
But what's really cool is that
GCS cloud, you notice I didn't
put that in one of
the data centers
when I made this slide.
That's actually globally
available to all data centers
simultaneously.
As soon as you get that confirm
back on that write,
you're able to use that snapshot
somewhere else.
So now, I can here take this
snapshot that I made from the
central region in the US and
deploy it in Western Europe
immediately after
I get the ACC.
So a couple quick notes on
using persistent disk.
I'm going to talk very briefly
about the things are kind of
obvious and well-documented, try
to spend a little bit of
time on things that are not 100%
obvious, but then I want
to hand it over to Andrew to
talk about best practices,
because I think that's why
a lot of people are here.
So the first thing is we have
a REST interface for
programmatic use
of the product.
And we have command line
and UI for more
administrative use.
And the commands are what
you'd expect them to be.
Create volume, delete volume,
mount volume, unmount volume.
It's all well-documented, and
everybody can see that.
So what does the volume
look like
inside the virtual machine?
The first thing to note is
that it shows up as a
VirtioSCSI device.
And it shows up with a symbolic
link to a device so
that you can easily find it.
Basically, the name that you
created it with will show up
in the device model inside the
VM, which'll help you find it
for mounting.
We do give you a command for
formatting and mounting the
volume, , which is actually
pretty useful.
Andrew will talk about
why we created that.
Talks basically about
block alignment
and performance assurance.
Now, if you want to make sure
that every time you create a
virtual machine a persistent
disk is mounted into it, a
couple ways you can do that.
First, if you're booting from
a PD, you obviously edit the
FS tab for any of the data
volumes you want to boot, you
want to mount, and that'll
always mount
properly the next time.
If you're going from a scratch
disk, though, you lose the FS
tab every time.
So you can use the custom
start-up scripts and the
custom metadata variables to
basically script your way
around making sure the data
drive mounts every time.
I did have some sample
code on that.
But everybody's embarrassed
of the PM shell scripting.
So it's in the backup slides.
Like any system,
PD has limits.
Limits are, like [? Urzhi ?]
mentioned this morning and I
think like [? Dabnev ?]
mentioned in the GCE talk today,
we've increased that.
Depending on the size of the VM
previously, it was anywhere
from 128 gig to 1 terabyte
volume limits.
Now, we've radically
increased that.
You can create 3 terabyte
volumes on the very small VMs,
the sub-core VMs, and up to
10 terabyte volumes on the
previous sized VMs.
And the number of devices--
four for the small VMs, 10
for the bigger VMs--
it's not 10 times 10 terabytes
for 100 terabytes.
It's 10 volumes adding
up to 100 terabytes--
I'm sorry.
10 volumes adding to 10
terabytes is the limit.
And so that should really take
care of pretty much any size
needs, I think, people have.
And compares, I think, very
favorably to other clouds.
Now, to ensure the consistent
performance, one of the things
we had to do was limit
the I/O rates.
So for large I/O blocks, you'll
hit a bandwidth limit
of somewhere around
120 megabytes.
And for smaller I/O, you'll
hit read I/O limitations.
Now, if you want to get more
smaller I/Os, you can add
multiple volumes to a VM and
stripe them together.
And Andrew will show some
data on that in the
best practices session.
And again, the 120 megabytes
is pretty good for a best
effort volume, right, as the
MapR guys found and talked
about in a previous slide.
Now, in terms of pricing, the
price is publicly listed.
What's good about this is like
GCE, the billing increment is
now very small.
So even though the price is per
month, when you create the
virtual disk, you don't get
charged for a whole month.
You only get charged for
the time that it lives.
And the increment is something
under five minutes.
If you want to see what your
price is at any given time,
how much you've accrued over the
course of a month, you can
go to the cloud console
and check that out.
One of the things to note is the
cloud console does update
its display on a daily basis.
But you're not actually getting
charged on a daily basis.
It's still accruing in very
small increments.
So don't panic when you
see that happen.
So that's kind of the overview
of what PD is, what it's good
for, and a little bit
of how it works.
And let me hand it over to
Andrew for how you guys can
get the most out of it.
ANDREW KADATCH: Thank you.
[? That was ?]
[? great ?].
When we started working on
persistent disk a while ago,
we put a couple of goals
ahead of us.
And the first and most important
one is durability.
If you lose data on the left and
on the right, everything
else doesn't matter.
Simple.
Second goal was security.
If I cannot trust my cloud
provider with my data, I'm not
going to use it.
So everything else doesn't
matter either.
To a [INAUDIBLE]-- so getting
back to durability.
So we replicate the data.
And we provide sufficient mean
time to data loss to say that
the system disk's mean time to
data loss exceeds mean time to
data loss of typical enterprise
class SATA disk by
one to two orders
of magnitude.
Security, what we do,
we encrypt the data.
And we encrypt it not only at
rest, but over the wire, too.
So it's extremely difficult
to get to the data.
And to be honest, I myself
don't have access to the
encryption keys.
So we made it as hard as
possible for ourselves.
High availability.
I should be able to get the
data when I most need it.
Typically, Tuesday morning
is the peak
traffic in cloud services.
And I they cannot get it,
my disk is unusable.
Typically, we are able to
achieve [? availability ?]
in I/O execution latency
within 3%.
The more cores the VM has and
the smaller the bandwidth, the
better availability and
consistency is.
The same applies
to consistency.
It's [? closely ?]
related to availability.
The thing about consistency is
that it's extremely important
for capacity planning.
Should I be running two
instances of my SQL services
or 20 to meet my peak demand?
I need to know up front.
And I need to plan
accordingly.
And finally, performance.
We bravely wanted to meet or
exceed performance of locally
attached SATA disks.
Obviously, mission impossible
because of encryption, network
latency, replication,
what not.
But I think overall, for many
services, we achieved pretty
good performance and it's
suitable for use.
However, before we'll talk about
specifics of persistent
disk, let me take a step back
and say that one lesson that
we all learn at Google
every day is simple.
The luck favors the prepared.
It was said by Louis Pasteur.
And he knew exactly
what he was doing.
So the problem is that
disasters do happen.
Human mistakes, software
bugs, natural disasters
happen all the time.
And we need to be prepared.
The way to get prepared
with persistent
disk is using snapshots.
Snapshots are a very
efficient way to
implement backup and restore.
The data is very distributed.
Snapshots are non-intrusive.
They are extremely efficient.
And most importantly,
they do not affect
performance of the volume.
So you can take it any time.
So I would strongly urge--
and probably will repeat it
multiple times-- to automate
the process.
Test it regularly.
And have regular snap shots.
What I would do, I would take
snapshots, say, hourly.
Keep a couple days of
hourly snapshots.
Then, I will remove all snap
shots and have a couple of
daily snapshots, a few weekly,
and a handful of monthly, just
in case, because sometimes we
don't know it is a problem
right away.
Sometimes it takes
time to discover.
And I should be able to get back
in time and restore my
database or my data set to
the correct state with
minimal data loss.
One thing is extremely
important.
We really have to use journaling
file systems when
we use persistent disk because
file systems cache a lot of
internal data structures
in memory.
And if those data structures in
memory are not preserved on
the disk in case of an
undesirable event, we will
have massive data loss.
And from our experiments, when
we use non-journaling file
systems and simulate various
failures under heavy load, we
are able to cause massive data
losses or irrecoverable file
system corruptions in
40%, 60% of cases.
It is very substantial.
Please, please use journaling
file systems.
Making snapshots
is really easy.
The safe way to do it is to
freeze application data files
and file system, make
a snapshot.
Making a snapshot is a
two phase operation.
One is making a snapshot,
effectively taking an
instantaneous photograph of
the volume state, and then
copying the data out.
When you start copying the data
out, the snapshot state
changes to upload.
And when we finish copying,
it becomes ready.
So the moment snapshot state
converts to uploading, it is
safe to release and then freeze
application and file systems.
Two caveats--
first of all, we need to
separate application data and
operating systems.
You cannot freeze OS partitions
or volumes.
It's as simple as that.
Secondly, for some applications
and some file
systems, it may be
not necessary.
For instance, if we run a SQL
Server which supports
transactions we run a journaling
file system, if you
just make a snapshot while
everything is running and
restore another VM from the
snapshot, it will look as if
there was a power failure
at the moment the
snapshot was taken.
File system will recover
from that.
SQL Server will recover
The problem is that
it may take time.
And it is different trade-off.
Sometimes, it's beneficial to
freeze and take a snapshot.
Sometimes, it's okay
to keep going.
Today, Google implements two
week maintenance windows every
quarter per cell.
And [? ICE ?]
is a wonderful opportunity to
make sure that your recovery
and scripts are working and
doing the right thing.
As a developer, when I joined
Google, I really hated that.
Now, I really love it.
It is a nice, forcing function
to ensure that we are doing
the right things, and our
products work, and they're
ready to face disasters.
Because they will happen.
And I would strongly recommend
visiting the next session.
They will have it on Friday at
2:00 PM in room number two by
Mark and Joe.
Maybe we will talk about
it a little bit more.
And we provide some tools to
simplify the migration of your
data and VMs to another cell
or zone using gcutil
[? moveinstances ?]
command.
That will make it fast
and efficient.
Or, if you prefer, you could
use your own scripts.
Amateurs back up.
Professionals restore.
Please, please, please automate
everything you can.
Take snapshots regularly.
Test your recovery routines.
And make sure that it works as
luck favors the prepared.
Now, let us proceed to
persistent disk [? repair. ?]
In many environments, it is a
well-known trick to create a
lot of volumes, test their
performance, and pick the one
that works the best and
throw away the rest.
It is not necessary to do with
persistent disk for a variety
of reasons.
We decide the actual data
placement at time of write.
So the past performance
doesn't matter.
We do exceptionally well
with noisy neighbors.
I would say about in 98%
of cases, if there is
interference at physical disk
level, we resolve it within
from two to 20 milliseconds.
So it's extremely efficient.
So I just took the data from
the last 10 automated
performance runs that
we run all the time.
Unfortunately, it's a
very boring slide.
There was much, much, much less
than 1% [? variability ?]
between runs.
Similarly, there is no need to
pre-warm the volume before
use, filling it with data, doing
full format, et cetera.
The volume is ready to use
and go from day one.
That is [? to our ?] run.
And those two horizontal lines
represent average I/O
execution latency and bandwidth,
respectively.
And to make the stuff a little
bit more interesting, we threw
a curveball.
That wavy line represents the
latency of the slowest I/O
during a one second period.
And as we see at one case about
30 minutes through the
run, it took about 3.5 times
slower than average, which is
not too bad.
So that's exactly [INAUDIBLE]
we did that.
Finally, we have something
interesting.
Three classic textbook
scalability drafts.
What happens if you stripe
volumes, which is yet another
well-known trick to improve
performance?
Yes, performance will improve
on small, random writes we
scale really well.
And max out at about six volumes
on small random rates,
will scale practically
linearly.
With large, sequential writes
which simulate [? bald ?] data
processing workload, they max
out, and then performance
drops because those volumes
start to compete with each
other at process level
and network.
But what I would like to
say, you can do that.
Nobody can stop you.
I would strongly discourage
you from doing
that because we would--
I don't like the need to do
something awkward and
extraordinary to get what
you should be getting.
We will change that.
You will get a way to get good
performance without the need
to go to extreme measures.
That's problem number one.
Problem number two, whenever
you stripe volumes,
reliability of the volume, mean
time to data loss, drops
dramatically.
And because we have absolutely
no control of what's going on
under the hood, unlike the
system disk where we have a
lot of control and we already
stripe it under the hood, you
will have degraded durability
of the volume.
Third, it is extremely difficult
to take consistent
snapshots of multiple volumes.
It is difficult and error-prone
to maintain those
small snapshots in time.
So if you have to, do it.
Otherwise, I would suggest
avoiding doing it.
Performance of persistent
disk supports latency--
well, mostly throughput and
number of I/Os per second
depend on I/O size and number
of I/Os in flight.
The more I/Os in flight we
have, the better the
performance.
The larger I/Os, the better
the throughput.
And as we could see from those
graphs, it is especially
noticeable in small
I/O blocks.
And we recommend to
use block size a
multiple of 4 kilobytes.
And I will talk about that
a little bit later.
The thing is that the system
disk internally is implemented
as a physical device with 4
kilobyte physical block and
512 byte logical block size.
It means that the minimal unit
of physical access to the unit
is 4 kilobytes.
Which means that if, for
instance, we are writing one
sector, 512 bytes, what will
happen under the hood?
We will read an entire 4
kilobyte block, modify a small
part of it, and write it back.
Read, modify, write
cycle is slow.
And actually, a lot of people
who are using modern hard
disks notice that because they
have 4 kilobyte physical
blocks, too.
Another thing that may happen,
even if we are doing
sequential I/O, if it's
misaligned, we will generate
not only read, modify,
write cycles.
But we will get overlapping I/Os
because each I/O will be
extended to the nearest
4 kilobyte boundary.
And then, they will
start to overlap.
And then, they will be
serialized so they don't
corrupt each other's data.
It is very slow.
Please, avoid doing that.
Typical mistakes people make is
partitioning their disks.
First of all, I would strongly
discourage doing that until
you absolutely have to do it.
There is no need to take a
large persistent disk and
partition it into multiple
subdisks.
It's better to just create
multiple disks.
Secondly, I would recommend
using modern tools, like
fdisk, one of the latest
generation, who do the right
things, to partition
if you have to.
And third thing, once you're
done partitioning a disk,
please double-check that
everything is right by running
fdisk -lu command.
And if you see that line in
red, the partition is
misaligned.
And if partition is misaligned,
all I/Os to that
partition will be misaligned
and will be extremely slow.
So that red line, it's
not something that I
tacked on the slide.
It's output from the command
so it's easy to grab.
So when we talk about file
system formatting, I would
recommend aligning partitions
on one megabyte boundaries,
default second for
modern fdisk, for
latest versions of fdisk.
I wouldn't recommend
modifying that.
I would recommend formatting
the disks with
four kilobyte blocks.
Use journaling file system.
And we provide instructions
and utilities
how to do that correct.
Another thing to talk about is
how we could use persistent
disk to efficiently
distribute data.
Well, as Jay mentioned, mounting
a persistent disk
read-only is a very efficient
way to distribute data within
the same zone.
What we could also do,
we could take a
snapshot of the disk.
And then, recreate a disk in
another zone and mount it read
only to another large
set of VMs.
And boom, within a few minutes,
we distributed a very
large data set across hundreds
of machines.
When we mount persistent disk
read only, I recommend you
measure the performance because
actual performance varies.
It depends on the
workload a lot.
We handle edge cases
extremely well.
But something in the
middle may vary.
It may scale from few hundreds,
from low hundreds,
to low thousands.
But you need to measure on your
specific workload on your
specific scenario.
Importing data from PD if you
have data sources somewhere
else is relatively easy.
We could use a [? CPO ?] or
gcutil push command to move
the data from your data
warehouse to a persistent
disk, from other storages
like blog
storages, object storages.
We can use tools provided
with them.
And for demanding applications
for accelerated data copying,
transferring huge quantities of
data, you may want to look
at third-party providers, like
Aspera who do that reliably
and efficiently.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Oh, thank
you, Andrew.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW KADATCH: I noticed you
got clapping when you
finished, but not me.
So thanks for joining.
We're going to go to Q&A
in a second here.
But just to summarize, first,
we talked about how
performance is optimized for
storing large, persistent data
for databases, whether
it's SQL or NoSQL.
We get rid of noisy neighbor
problems, whether it be on
reads or writes by distributing
the data, writing
to free disks, and reading
from whoever's
available most quickly.
Besides scaling on data access,
we scale on the boot
devices by deploying extremely
quickly and using shared
blocks wherever we can.
So we can handle those burst
use cases, like Greg was
talking about this morning.
And again, all these services
are better together.
Using GCS for your backups and
your DR gets data off-site
super fast, and then also is
able to give you more scale--
again, this massive read-only
mount use case we talked about
for scientific computing,
or rendering, or
other things like that.
And lastly, hopefully it wasn't
too scary, but we did
give you a lot of best
practices, a lot of ways to
keep your data safe, and to
keep it working very fast.
So follow the best practices
that Andrew shared with you.
The slides are available,
so you don't have
to remember it all.
And I guess let's turn
it over to questions.
Thank you very much
for joining.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So we're running various
Hadoop clusters today,
currently on [? native disks. ?]
And we use instant storage,
which is not very
satisfactory, because they're
quite small volumes, as you
probably know.
So two questions, really.
One is it sounds like you're
saying that you can use PDs as
disks for HDFS data nodes, and
that the I/O is probably good
enough, or compatible with
instant storage.
Is that what you're saying?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: So yeah.
What the MapR guys found--
I haven't used this personally,
but the MapR guys
basically said, if you use the
scratch disk from Google, it
will perform better.
I mean, they basically took--
when they optimized the MapR
FS, similar to how HDFS was
done, it was optimized for
locally attached SATA devices.
Now, they just found some of
their customers couldn't use
that because they were going to
shut down the whole cluster
instead of one VM at a time.
And what they found was PD
was actually fast enough.
They thought it wasn't going
to be, based on experience
with other clouds.
So I'm not going to say it was,
in that use case, as fast
as scratch.
But they were able to stream
120 megabytes to a volume.
And if that's good enough for
you, and if you value the
flexibility of being able to
shut down the cluster more
than the raw performance,
then it's a good option.
It's just a flexibility versus
performance trade-off, but
you're going to do pretty
good either way.
AUDIENCE: So my follow up
question is, that third use
case you talked about, the
parallel read case, actually,
that's my preferred option
because actually,
realistically, I'd rather just
be able to shut down the whole
cluster and bring it
up instantaneously.
And if I've got HDFS running,
it's hard to do that.
So are there any limitations to
that parallel read in terms
of the number of instances and
the combined throughput you
could have [INAUDIBLE]
with it?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: So like Andrew
was saying, it is going to be
a little bit dependent
on the workload.
If you think about how we
architected it, where all the
data from a particular volume
is striped out across
thousands of disks, if you mount
it to a lot of VMs and
each of those VMs are accessing
different parts of
the disk, you're actually
going to get additive
performance.
I mean, it's going to perform
like-- it's going to seem to
defy the laws of physics because
you're going to have
hundreds of VMs accessing
hundreds of blocks on hundreds
of physical devices over
hundreds of NICs.
Now, let's say you have the
opposite case where somehow,
you've synchronized it so that
ever VM reads from the same
block at the same
exact moment.
We're smart enough not to go
to disk each time on that.
But you're going to throttle
the network card on the few
machines that are holding
onto that block.
So it's going to depend
on your workload.
The more random the access, the
more linear that thing's
going to scale.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Very briefly, you mentioned
that it behaves very, very
well with the EXT3 and EXT4.
Have any of the other funkier
file systems been tried with
any degree of success?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Is "funky"
a technical term?
AUDIENCE: I believe so, yes.
ANDREW KADATCH: Excuse me, I
didn't hear the question.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: He asked, beside
EXT3 and EXT4, are
there other file systems
we played with?
ANDREW KADATCH: Yes.
We played with other
file systems.
We liked performance of EXT4
in our tests, aggregate
workloads, aggregate performance
across a variety
of workloads that we tried
on, which is by no means
representative or matching
your specific needs.
It did the best overall.
AUDIENCE: Okay, thank you.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Other
questions?
Still have five more minutes,
so we'll have them lock the
doors and make you
ask questions.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
a quick question?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Hey,
absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So if you get to the
point where you need a big
chunk of it to come down, is
there a best practice for
downloading from the
persistent disk?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: I apologize.
You're actually way taller
than the mic.
Can you--?
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering if
you get to the point where
you actually want to retrieve
the data, are there best
practices for being able to
download it efficiently to
your local system?
ANDREW KADATCH: There are
multiple ways to do it.
And I think what I'll
say applies
to most cloud storages.
Like I said, using similar
means, you would copy the data
to another machine.
Or you could copy it
to [? up-cloud ?]
object storage, or
for instance,
Google Cloud Storage.
And we can get your data
available from anywhere.
So there are a variety of
ways to accomplish that.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: So Google Cloud
Storage in particular, if
you're uploading to cloud
storage, you can use the
parallelism and the object
composition to
get stuff up quickly.
In terms of downloading from
Google Cloud Storage, you have
the ability to--
what are the things in terms of
download we can do in GCS?
Gcutil is this optimized for
getting as much data down as
quickly as possible.
And they are working--
yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: How do you guys manage
your encryption keys,
and can I supply my
own custom ones?
ANDREW KADATCH: May I ask you
to talk into the microphone?
JAY JUDKOWITZ: How are we
managing encryption keys?
ANDREW KADATCH: There is a
service which owns those keys.
And they are passed to the VM.
VM itself cannot query those
keys, or ask to give it to it.
If you know the top layer,
management layer, we just
trust the one, and transmit on
separate machines and the
separate accounts.
If it believes that this VM
should be able to mount the
disk, it gives it the command to
do so and passes the keys.
Nobody else is able to
access those keys.
We restrict the access.
And it's audited, et
cetera, et cetera.
JAY JUDKOWITZ: Well, thank
you all very much again.
I hope you enjoy the
rest of the show.
Thanks for your time.
Oh, and if you have any follow
up stuff, anything you want to
talk about in terms of feedback,
feature requests,
anything, do feel free to reach
out to Andrew and I
directly or the mailing list
on the last slide.
OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]